hello my name is valentin covenant so
i'll be doing this tutorial
on complexity around sat
satisfiability is really such an
important problem and complexity
all complexity theorists love sad
and i'm hoping to show you some of the
things
which make sat such a favorite with
complexity theories
and for me the topic of this tutorial is
more like
dancing around satisfiability because
doing complexity
often feels like dancing around sat
and i'm hoping to tell you some
basics about sat
its importance because of empty
completeness and its connections to
other complexity classes
and other research directions and
complexity so you see in this picture
different things that we'll be talking
about starting with
the basics and the completeness and then
moving on to things like palm of mail
time hierarchy
interactive proofs pcp theorem and so
forth
and some more advanced topics like lower
bounds for satisfiability
um exponential time hypothesis
approximate counting uniform generation
of sad witnesses
and learning so there's a lot of stuff
to cover
really and uh saying that this is
sat center complexity theory is really
like not saying much
because i can still talk about
everything in computational complexity
pretty much
so let's start at the beginning
the end the completeness of sat that's
uh where sat made its entrance into the
complexity
world with this big bang
people realize that satisfiability is
such an important problem
and then complexity theory from then on
from where it happened in 1971
exactly 50 years ago from then on sat
has become a central figure
central character in this complexity
saga
so steve cook and 11 proved that through
satisfiability
is and be complete so i'll explain
things fairly
slow so let's start with 3sat what is a
3sat
you're given a cnf formula
like this one here you see each clause
contains a disjunction of three
literals a variable or negation of a
variable
you have conjunctions of such clauses of
size three and that's your
three cnf conjunctive normal form with
each clause of size three
and the basic question given such a
formula such as 3c and f
is satisfiable where of course
satisfiable means that you can assign
true false value to the prepositional
variables x1 x2 x3 and so forth
true false value such that when you
avoid the formula
it becomes true so is it possible to
satisfy given formula
and we don't know how to do that and we
didn't know how to do that
back in 1971 or even of course before
then so initial question is
is there a polynomial time algorithm
for deciding satisfiability of three
cnfs
why three well if you go lower than
three to say two cnfs
then we do know how to solve those in
polynomial time
so if your clauses are with two rather
than three
then there is a non-trivial but not very
complicated polynomial time algorithm
for
solving this task but three seems to
have
a monumental challenge for computer
algorithms for efficient computer
algorithms
so what's going on
and basically cook 11 independently
showed that the reason why three side is
so difficult is because
basically it has very many different
phases
if you can solve three satisfiability in
polynomial time
that then you not only do you get an
algorithm for for three satisfiability
but you get
a polynomial time algorithm for a whole
class
of seemingly different problems
and this class has a name and p stands
for non-deterministic polynomial time
and contains tons of interesting
problems that people care about
and have been looking at for quite some
time before the discovery of
anticompleteness in 1971.
so i want to explain p and p and p
completeness
so let me start even before 1971
going back to 1930s and the definition
of a tuning machine
because talk about polynomial time
algorithms so we need to fix
some model of computation and tuning
machine
is the most convenient one and still the
model of computation
primarily used in complexity theory to
talk about efficiency or inefficiency of
solving different problems
so tuning machine is a very simple model
of computation
it's a computational device which has
an infinite tape partitioned into cells
you see blank symbol 001
those are separate symbols and separate
tape
cells and it has a finite control
which on the one hand scans the tape in
a particular tape cell you see
here it scans a position with symbol
zero
and it's in some state out of finitely
many states right now it's in state
q and the main part of the queuing
machine description
of course is a program program telling
the machine what to do and the program
basically looks like the following kinds
of
commands if then else statements it says
that if your current state is something
and you see a particular symbol then
update your state to maybe
something new update the symbol that
you're
looking at scanning uh to something new
or keep it the same
and then move on the tape position to
the right or position to the left
okay so in this case for example after
looking at the symbol 0 we can maybe
replace it with a 1
and start looking at next symbol on the
right hand side
and i won't be using this that much but
i'll just mention that you have a
special initial state q naught
and you have special holding state q
accept which signals that you accepted
a given input so you say yes or q reject
which means that you reject the q
enabled the important thing about the
tuning machine model and this will be a
theme
uh central to complexity theory from
then on from 1970s on and in particular
that's the property that was exploited
in the proof of ku kleven's theorem as
i'm going to show
to you it's the locality of computation
the turing machine model presents their
local view on what's happening
with the state of computation
so if you look at the tape you scan a
particular symbol of the tape
what happens will be centered in that
table cell location or maybe its
immediate neighbor
immediate neighbor to the left or
immediate neighbor on the right
everything else stays untouched as it
was before
so the action is happening there locally
we'll come back to this point
in a moment when we'll discuss the tween
machine um
the proof of cook levin theorem for the
tree machine model
the time complexity of between machine
is naturally defined as the number of
computation steps
the number of transitions you make the
number of commands in this table
of comments that your machine has
that you need to take before you reach
an accepting or
rejecting state we ignore here the halt
in non-halting issues we assume that all
the
tuning machines will be timed so that
they will always terminate
now we can define a class p as a class
of as a class of
polynomial time solvable problems
problems
yes no decision problem solvable by
polynomial time running
deterministic tree machine so far
everything is deterministic
np on the other hand
stands for the class of those problems
which is also solvable
in polynomial time but in a different
more general
conventional model of so-called
non-deterministic tune machines
and the difference between deterministic
and non-linguistic is that the program
has more options for the then
statement here deterministically you say
okay if the situation was like so before
if this what happened before
then in the next step step of the
computation this is what must happen
but in non-domestic machine case
you may have options you may have do
this
or do that or do that some constant
number of options
and then norms machine will have to
choose which of those options to follow
and we imagine that kind of different
machines are created
that follow different options
so this is not a model that you can
easily implement and the whole point of
this
nonstick model is that it's a conceptual
thing rather than
an actual thing you can implement in
practice and
defining np this way of course is
perfectly fine but personally
i prefer the following equivalent way of
defining np where you have a certain
game
between approver and a verifier
both of them are given an input
x binary strength say of certain length
and the prover is trying to convince the
verifier that the string
is accepted should be part of the
of the language or should be yes
instance of your problem in question
and the proverbial will send a witness
to the verifier and the witness is some
binary string
of not too long length of polynomial
length in the length of x
and the verifier will look at the input
x and we'll look at the
witness sent by the prover and will
accept or reject accordingly
and we say that x is accepted by the
spoover verifier pair
if and only if the verifier will
accept the input x and the witness y
provided by the prover
and note that the verifier here is
completely deterministic polynomial time
algorithm
of course um you can think of this as
a non-limited computation where um
the prover is the non-domestic part of
the of the algorithm
so you're monitoring guessing this
witness y
of polynomial of polynomial length and
then you deterministically
check the guest witness for being
correct or not correct
as a simple illustration of the point is
let's look one let's look at three set
and see why three starters in
np uh here the input to the poor
verifier will be
a three center formula phi let's say in
some variables x1 through xn
and the witness of course will be a
candidate satisfying assignment which is
a bit binary string
and the verifier's job is very easy it
looks at formula five
looks at the witness y sent by the
prover and make sure that this is a
satisfying assignment that phi of y
is actually equal to one as as always
common
i will identify true with one false with
zero and talk about boolean functions
true false
predicates uh as the same things
okay to talk about anti-completeness we
still need to define more things we need
to talk about the notion of reduction
which helps us to compare
the conditional difficulties of the
problem reductions are really
the main thing that complexity theories
study
so you say that the problem a is
polynomial time reducible to problem b
where a problem is simply a collection
of binary strings out of all possible
binary strings
it's a collection of yes instances of a
problem if you like
so we say problem a is reducible to b in
polynomial time
if there exists a way um there's a
polynomial time
mapping an algorithm polynomial time
algorithm which map strings to strings
such that for every string
x x is in the problem on the left x is
an a if and only if
the value of the reduction r of x is a
member of the problem on the right
so x is an a if and only if r of x is in
b and here's a picture
you see that our reduction is supposed
to map
instances yes instances of a to yes
instances of b
and no instances of a must be mapped to
no instances of b
so reductions somehow maps yes to yes
no to no and it's not hard to see and
that's the whole point
of uh having such reduction is that
if a problem a is reducible to b in
polynomial
time and if the problem b itself can be
solved in polynomial time
then together the reduction plus the
algorithm for the problem b
will give you a polynomial time
algorithm for problem a
okay so that's what i meant by saying
that a
is easier than b if you have a reduction
from a to b
and finally we can define the notion of
anti-completeness as
follows the problem b say is called
np-complete
if it's a member of the class np it has
this proven verifier
definition and every other problem
a in the class and p is easier than b
so every other problem a in the class
and b is repolymeral time reducible
to b so what it means is that an np
complete problem is like the hardest
problem
in the class np it is a member of the
class condition one
and everything else in the class is
reducible to it
efficiently in polynomial time so if you
haven't picked up the problem
and if suddenly you can solve it in
polynomial time
then everything in monoxic polynomial
time also becomes
solvable in polynomial time
and now we can state the cook 11 theorem
with all the notation
defined so cleveland cook and lemon
prove that three satisfiability is
mp complete to prove this
i'm gonna give you a proof of this at
least some
level of detail we'll need to show the
following
we'll need to give a generic way of
saying if i have a problem
a in non-activistic polynomial time
then there will be a polynomial time
efficient reduction capital r
which will map access to inputs x
which are instances of problem a to
formulas
which i denote by phi sub x in some
variables
y so that by the definition of reduction
axis in the problem a is a yes instance
of a problem a
if and only if the formula 5 sub x is a
yes instance of 3 sat which of course
means
that phi sub x is a satisfiable 3
cnf actually what we'll show
will be something stronger will pay
attention
not only to the fact that you have a
reduction
but we want also to measure the size of
the formula phi of x
phi sub x as a function of the input
length
of x and we'll show the following
result if i have a language a in
non-intrinsic polynomial time
in some specific non-histic time t of m
so think of t of n as quadratic cubic or
linear if you like
so then i have i'll have a reduction
that will map
input x of length n to a three c f
formula phi sub x
satisfying the condition of the
reductions as usual x's and
a if and only if the formula five sub
axis and three sat
but also the size of the formula
phi sub x will be almost linear
in the run time of the algorithm for a
so algorithm for a longer algorithm for
a was running in time
t then the size of the formula phi sub x
that we'll get as a result of the
seduction
will be almost t it will be big o of t
times log t
so it's quasi-linear almost linear in
running time
and that's as efficient as we know how
to do it at the moment
the proof of this is not anything new
it's fairly well known but
the usual proof that people normally see
when they talk about anti-completeness
in a basic
course on algorithms or complexity is
that
this they build the size of the formula
whose size is quadratic
in the runtime so they get uh the size
of the
sub x formula be about big o of t square
actually we'll prove a somewhat stronger
result
i will talk not about non-intrinsic time
t but about
deterministic time t which
jumping ahead a little bit is not really
much of a difference
because we can define normal component
of time using the deterministic verifier
and we only need to worry about this
deterministic verifier algorithm
okay so we'll prove that for
deterministic time t computation
we can build an equivalent
circuit of size almost t
so time t is in circuit size
t log t so basically we
have efficient simulation of algorithms
by
circuits and the two
objects are represented in this picture
that you see on the slide right now
on the left hand side you have a tuning
machine
and the input to the tune machine let's
fix some input length n
so a particular input is some sequence
of n bits x
equal to x1 through xn and the tuning
machine is
whatever standard small computation
description with if statements saying if
say this
and simple this then state that and
assemble that and so forth and you have
a moment left or right each time
we've seen that before uh on the other
hand
um the circuit computing the unsure
uh the same answer yes no the true
machine
would compute is the following object it
has
logical connectives in this case it's
negations
uh conjunctions and ors
we call them gates logical gates not
gates
and gate or gates and they form this
graph and you have inputs
fed into your circuit you have n inputs
coming in
and then the signal propagates to the
circuit in the obvious way
each key it computes the end of its
incoming signals
and the information is traveling from
top to down
and the last output gate of the circuit
is the bottom gate on this picture which
gives you the final answer from the
circuit
and so what we want to show is that if i
have a
uniform tuned machine computation model
where tune machine
runs on inputs of length n and takes
time
t t of n then i can
build a circuit moreover efficiently
construct from the definition of the
tuning machine
a circuit that will do the exact same
thing
except the same inputs and reject the
same inputs as the tuning machine would
and the size of that circuit measured as
the number
of gates in this graph
will be at most t times log t
okay so from that as we shall see
and for now just believe me that it's
possible it will be easy consequence
that we can show that we can deduce cook
11 steering
from that result that allows you to
simulate
algorithms with boolean circuits
okay and we'll do that
next